cela fait quatre cent dix huit années
que chacun que chez à la même époque et
le même jour qu'il ouvre ses portes aux
petits et aux grands et aux petits et
aux grands voilà en moins d'un mois et
bien il va lui miner plus d'un regard
est en tout cas celui de jean-françois
de l'isi qui comme chacun sait est resté
un grand enfant
je veux bien sûr parler du marché de
noël le christ kindle ce méric un must
en matière de reportages télévisés oui
comme vous venez de voir mme america's
est capable de retenir sa son a fait
quatre cent dix huit ans que le marché
existe presque autant qu'en mal filmé
inutile donc de vous dire qui les place
broglie qui lie à une quarantaine de
commerçants autant d'artisans une
vingtaine de marchands de sapin vous le
savez déjà
seul d'ailleurs la conscience
professionnelle et un rédacteur en chef
de très mauvaise humeur nous ont empêché
de rester bien au chaud et de vous
repasser les images de l'an passé ou
d'il ya deux ans ou trois ou quatre ou
cinq ou six ou sept ou huit dates
ça fait combien de temps vous êtes là
comme un damné de beats existe
vous savez plus combien de temps ce avec
une dizaine d'îles 12 ans ou 120 dont
418 418 ouais j'suis a besoin d'encore
ça fait combien de temps qu'on vient
vous filmer chaque année pratiquement
tout dernier à toutes les années parce
qu'on est les meilleurs fait normal hein
alors que faire si vous savez tout à
part poser des questions stupides a de
bien jolies dames venues montrer vos
muscles a cessé de s'accroître la fin
j'ai froid ça
fait mieux on sait
voilà alors quand je vois là puisque son
histoire
s'il vous plaît on cherche le père noël
vous l'avez pas vu pourquoi ce qui n'est
pas la fille sympa
d'habitude il est là bas c'est encore
les temps et puis comme noël c'est aussi
le moment d'évoquer les cas désespérés
voilà notre bonne action paix sur la
terre aux hommes de bonne volonté
en tout cas nous on a fait ce qu'on a pu
alors il paraît que vous en avez besoin